let's jump to the story from Fox News
Harvard Medical School offers course
about health care for
lgbtqia plus
infants the course promises to focus on
serving gender and sexual minority
people across the lifespan
what is that what does that mean in
lgbtqi infant preview bestant human
beings who haven't formed the ability to
speak have already formed sexual
identity is that what they're saying I
think that's what they're trying to say
yes I mean and this is coming from
Harvard this yeah this story we were
made aware of this story today and we
did a video on it one of our members did
a video on it and it's just it's
I don't have the proper words to
describe it you know it's like
there is no red line how can they claim
that infants are lgbtqia but then also
claim it's it's social condition right
yeah that's an interesting one this
argument is that it's inherent within
all people
um which is it right I mean how are how
how
okay so my thing is children uh that
includes infants and babies they cannot
they're they're they don't understand
what uh sexuality is you know they don't
they don't have these feelings so they
they cannot be
um any sexuality like they're just not
developmentally there yet and the fact
that babies are even being thrown into
this I mean it's almost like a mockery I
mean they just keep throw you know
making things worse and throwing more
and more at the wall and just I think
it's to shame everybody just a
humiliation ritual basically of like
this is what our country is turning it's
also for profit oh no that is the main
that is the main thing behind it all I
mean you know they the big Pharma and
and all these hospitals with their
gender clinics they see they just see
these walking dollar signs I mean like
to to get a child hooked up into this
system
um and get on these you know hormones
and puberty blockers and then eventually
the surgeries and what else the the
maintenance that that requires is a
lifetime I mean they are lifetime
patients and so when they get them young
I mean these are the these are a million
dollars each maybe more than a million
dollars each throughout their lifetime
you know it's an ongoing thing until the
day they die they're going to be needing
these things to maintain it
um so I think that that is like the
number one motivator behind this entire
movement
um but yeah it's it's talk about loyal
customers oh yeah because you have to
keep buying the pillows you have to
because you're doing the procedures and
there's a lot of complications with them
I believe there's a monetary incentive
but I also think there's a larger kind
of deeper incentive when it comes to
breaking down the family unit and I
think there's even potentially an even
bigger agenda when it comes to a
transhumanist agenda which of course is
also going to be very important with the
fourth fourth Industrial Revolution that
the world economic forum is pushing
where they want to have people that are
non-binary non-identified with their
actual sex and are just cyborgs of the
machine yeah I can see that for sure I
don't think that you you know Pharma is
the only um motivator here but I think
it's a big one but yeah there's a bunch
there's others but Tim I see you holding
a interesting book I haven't read it
I've seen enough you need to read it
I've seen pictures and nope I haven't
seen enough okay well I've seen enough
to know that it belongs nowhere near
children and you know like these uh
these people
um these activists these radical
activists that have hijacked our
movement and people that use our
community you know to like to push all
this stuff they're up in arms over book
Banning they call it book Banning and
it's like it's pornography in kids
schools and libraries like pornography
for kids should be banned like I'm sorry
what they you know they always try to
think education oh
got it well that's that's it's so it's
like a lot of people on the right are
calling it porn and I'm like well some
of it yeah but I think it's more Kink
education which is which is worse it's
one thing for like an adult to be like I
am aroused and enjoy watching this it's
another thing if you have like a
curriculum where it's like here's how to
use an insertion device when I say
pornography like I don't mean you know
like it's literal pornography but you
know the writing it's suggesting I mean
it's sexual activities it's uh in great
detail and exploring that encouraging
you know young children to explore that
within themselves the reason I ask you
if you read it because we talked about
this quite a bit the other day the book
is actually
very little about the weird sexual
explicit stuff and overtly about how her
parents were extremely abusive towards
her and she couldn't read till she was
12. she would pee in the yard she
smelled so bad the counselor had to pull
her out of class and tell her like
people are complaining about your stench
and she was wearing menstrual pads that
were so old they were crusted with blood
that was flaking off into her pants it's
no wonder she doesn't want to be a woman
oh right it's not it's not an issue of
like I feel a different way it's that
her parents were extremely abusive
towards her so we're talking about like
lgbtqia kids yeah no I don't I I think
they're totally wrong about this we were
talking to the Hodge twins and they were
saying that they thought that a lot of
this stuff is learned and I said I don't
think so and they said well if it's not
learned then how could you groom a kid
and I was like you can abuse and
traumatize a kid into doing all sorts of
crazy things you can get someone to
smoke cigarettes smoking cigarettes
isn't good for you right you can get
people to do things but what I was
saying is like if you take like humans
free of anything else and have them run
around once they grow up they will
figure out how to procreate if you
traumatize and abuse them you will cause
fear panic and and you know problems in
their future so they're talking about
lgbtqia kids
that's why I'm telling everybody to at
least you know figure out how to look at
the beginning of this book because
what's really showing is how these
people get traumatized and beaten into
being terrified of who they are hating
who they are I understand that like the
the thing in question in this book where
she's like is is getting the the
pleasure you know the adult act she says
she hates it and then the end says she
doesn't want to do any of this and is
asexual and doesn't want to be involved
and it's like yeah just absolute trauma
trauma and abuse and so what's happening
is these people who are traumatized want
to share that trauma with the Next
Generation and push it onto them I think
that's definitely part of it I think
that the people that are traumatized
though they they do want to do that I
think there's much more behind it though
too I mean
um
yeah I mean these this book is one of
many right that are just you know that
that cover this topic and other
inappropriate topics
um
but uh yeah and and in terms of grooming
kids I mean you can I I believe that you
are born gay like I I believe that
um you can be born gay and like nothing
happened to me as a kid nothing I know
so many gay people they had great
childhoods nothing you know a lot of
people say like oh you you were
traumatized or abused or whatever like a
million a myriad of different um
possibilities to clarify I'm referring
to someone who says I am not a woman and
I don't want to be romantic with anybody
it's like that feeling right there is
because her parents were abusing her
yeah no I know I'm getting there I'm
saying but uh you were saying like um
that
what did you say exactly you were saying
that like uh kids can't be you none of
this stuff can be learned or or um I'm
referring to like the non-binary gender
stuff yeah we're talking about like
lgbtqia plus infants or whatever I'm
saying that I agree with you like I
think people like I I think some people
are just gay some people yeah you know
but as far as like the non-binary and
when we're getting into like gender
ideology and gender identity I mean I
think that that can very very strongly
be manufactured and implanted in kids
heads and like even be seen as trendy
now which it is you know like um I have
um my fiance's sister uh she's in her
teens and
um she goes to school obviously and like
she's she was telling us how like it's
not even okay it's not even you're not
cool enough if you're just gay anymore
you know so these kids are this is just
being this culture being
um put into these schools and just into
into society you know through media and
everything that that it's very very
trendy and I think that I mean I think
that gender identity is definitely
something that can be manufactured and
to lead these kids into believing that
they were born in the wrong body because
they don't fit perfectly into like a
little binary stereotype box you know
well that's exactly it like this book
really outlines that and I think if
people are are trying to understand
what's causing people to experience this
look at what happens you get a little
girl her parents let her run around wild
in the yard peeing in the yard there's
like no supervision they don't even like
she couldn't read till she was 12.
that's a big one right there that's a
huge indicator of abuse oh yeah but she
draws a picture of a menstrual pad
crusted with black blood it's in the
first like the first portion of the book
and she's like I would wear these for
days with the blood flaking off like
coffee grounds and it's just like this
person isn't non-binary right they are
they are they they had a mother who
didn't tell her how to live and how to
be hygienic how to clean her body and
how to socialize so when she was
rejected by Society for being a and I
mean this without like I'm not trying to
be mean but filthy literally and
unhygienic and and smelling like feces
she rejects it and says it's an issue of
being a woman no that's not being a
woman right being a woman isn't isn't
smelling bad and being made fun of and
insulted but she Associates those things
because
she's like you really read and it's like
she lives in the wilderness basically
and then when she tries to socialize
with normal kids she can't read and
communicate properly or socialize I've
heard of other stories about that like
where where these children are so abused
and neglected like I forget the name but
um you know she was locked in a basement
for like the first 12 years of her life
didn't know how to talk at all like knew
nothing and obviously you know that's
that's a rare case I mean maybe not so
rare I don't know but like that case in
terms of uh becoming
genderqueer or non-binary or whatever I
don't know I mean that's one reaction to
to this kind of abuse but yeah the fact
that yeah but but you know there's a
saying that's like hurt people hurt
people right so like now this person is
writing her story and that's fine share
your story but it's one thing to write
it and get it out there and share it
with the world and then another to want
it in kids hands right you know like
even that that topic of just abuse like
I I truthfully I didn't know that was
all in that book like you know I've seen
um bits of it online but I I I've never
um well then and then with all that
abuse she writes about how she goes to
the queer straight Alliance and they're
all cheering for her and saying all
right they love her so imagine you smell
like crap you've got dried blood in your
pants for days your counselor is telling
you like you smell like crap something's
wrong with you you've got hairy legs the
girls are making fun of and you can't
read and you're peeing in the floor and
then someone comes and says I affirm you
you're okay and I love you all of a
sudden you feel good and you say please
I will do anything give me more of this
feeling right yeah that's a cycle of it
is the abuse that the person takes on
they start to rationalize as normal and
okay and it wasn't the abuse it was the
problem it was the gender whatever and
then when they get older and they're
around kids they're like you know what
that abuse that I experienced it is okay
so if I do it to you there's nothing
wrong with that and then that cycle you
know you gotta accept like it wasn't
okay what your mom did to you Maya that
wasn't okay you should have been ahead
clean pants man you should they should
have been there for you
yeah that's a you know important issue
people who are you know abused uh
sometimes come out as abusers themselves
or they go the other direction and they
become Advocates against the abuse and
it could go either one of those two ways
depending on the human being depending
how they're raised uh but I I just kind
of wanted to ask you since you're kind
of looking into this uh you know a lot
of this is in our schools in our
entertainment and our social media I
mean this is going to have a lot of
long-term effects not only on the family
unit but of course on on everyone being
dependent on big Pharma everyone's
emotions and hormones being all
dysregulated uh what do you see here as
the end game how do how would you even
quantify why do you this is the question
why is this happening
yeah that's a big question
um well like I touched on before I truly
think big Pharma is um one of the main
two motivators uh well maybe there are
more than two
um but big Pharma the profits obviously
um getting them hooked up to that system
I also think pedophilia is a huge
motivator behind it because I mean it's
not just about the transitioning of
children medically you know it's like
the whole thing it's the sexualization
the introducing them to sexual to sexual
um content and material and events with
the drag stuff
um you know having them now dance on
stage for dollar bills all of this I
think is definitely rooted in the
normalization of pedophilia I think that
that has been happening for a long time
that's been the goal for a long time and
you know back when when we were fighting
for just the right to get married and
and people would warn of the slippery
slope you know like well what's going to
come next pedophilia is next and I I
genuinely thought these people were
insane because all I wanted was the
right to marry and I was happy to pack
it up and go home after that and I think
we all should have gone home after that
like I don't know why these events are
still taking place when we have all of
our rights like we won the game go home
and now you know so I back then I
thought those people were absolutely
insane that rewarding of the slippery
slope but now we're here and I'm like
well they were right you know turns out
they were right and the push has always
been to normalize pedophilia with and I
think the end game here is to get a p
attached to our acronym our ever-growing
acronym
um there's a few peas already is there
yeah pan oh well it's not it's not in
the official acronym but yeah
I don't know I don't know I don't abide
by it none of us do we don't like that
but who makes the flag for that matter
you know it's a good question like I was
I was in Donald Frederick and I saw uh
uh it's it was the pride flag with the
black and brown on it and the trail ugly
and an eagle an eagle yeah I haven't
seen the eagle one I've seen the one
with the circle the yellow circle with
like a purple circle in it or something
I don't know what that means I don't
know what any of this means and then
another one just came out recently with
like do you remember like the Red
Umbrella yeah the pucker at anus what is
that it's it's a symbol of sex work
they call it an umbrella but you know
okay you know what it is it's a booty
hole Yeah it's a booty hole perfect I've
always been really
LGB is like its own to me yeah someone's
gay they're bi they're they're less
whatever lesbians are kind of gay so
it's almost like redundant but like
what's the difference just like it's a
label you say your name is it the way
you want is it what you want like what
makes you gay in your opinion wanting it
or the act and not wanting it at all but
having the act happen
um being gay is a I mean I'm
romantically attracted to women you know
I am physically attracted to women I
only want to be with women you know I
can I can appreciate if a man is
handsome or not but I feel nothing
towards them so it's being gay isn't an
act for me it's a feeling I mean it's
who I am like you know it's part of me
but at the same time I I cannot stand
people that make being gay or whatever
they are trans their entire identity you
know I look at being gay me being gay is
like the same as I have dark hair I'm
also gay you know I also like wearing
Adidas jackets I don't know it's just
something about me you know it's part of
me but it's not all of me it's not all
of who I am yeah do you find that scale
the Kinsey scale I was told about my
buddy in college was a gay dude he was
like oh yeah everyone's on the Kinsey
scale now I'm finding out Alfred Kinsey
was right psychopath yeah that's funny
trying to sexualized people I went to
Indiana University so like I had and I
took a lot of psychology classes and I I
was in the Kinsey building a lot that
Kinsey Institute of whatever psychology
and now they um just recently they put
up a statue of him right outside and so
you know gays against rumors we want to
have a protest down there actually to
get that statue removed because he's
sick I mean he he he experimented
sexually on on babies I think like as
young as two yeah to come up with the
Kinsey scale you know I watched that you
ever see the movie Kinsey with like Liam
Neeson or whatever I think his name is
um and it was like they made him look
good he was the hero obviously you know
like he was good he was the Hollywood
hero but it was a i this was before I
knew all this Insidious stuff about
Kinsey
um I loved that movie I I used to rate
myself on the Kinsey scale you know
before I knew all this but basically the
Kinsey scale is that zero you're
completely heterosexual
six you're completely homosexual and
that the idea was like the majority of
the population Falls somewhere in
between not necessarily exactly in the
middle but maybe like a 5.5 or like a
2.3 you know like it's not always so
black and white
but that that's yeah and this was the
father of the sexual Revolution right I
think so yeah him and John money John
money we actually just wrote an article
our um we have a team of writers and we
just put up an article on our site um
gays againstgroomers.com on our blog
about uh John money he is the Godfather
of gender identity and gender theory he
did he he's famous for the David I think
his name is David Reimer
um he basically David was born I think a
hermaphrodite twin boys yeah no they
were twin boys but one of them was a
hermaphrodite no the botched
circumcision oh is that what it was okay
they bought the circumcision and then he
said well here's what we can do you're
right because gender is a social
construct we can raise him as a female
and give him female hormones and he
won't know the difference and he was
never told about this so he was raised
as a girl and he ended up killing
himself in like his 20s both did well no
one died from a drug overdose I think
but like the David I think intentionally
like
yeah I'm reading about Kinsey right now
and I think he was connected to the
Rockefeller foundation and he's also a
eugenicist John money that had these
prepubescent kids simulating sex acts on
each other yeah and then David who I
believe was the the being raised as a
female
rejected the female identity and kept
trying to do boyish things and they kept
desperately trying to force the
socialization of being female but David
kept saying no and then finally the
parents were like okay the depression is
too severe something's wrong here we
have to tell him the truth tell her the
truth and then yeah that whole time
still had no idea immediately
detransitioned and said this was wrong
you shouldn't have done this to me I you
know I don't feel that way and then
tried reversing the process eventually
just committed suicide mm-hmm and then
later I think his brother was just so
depressed also and just so messed up
from the whole thing you know because I
don't think he had any idea either that
he ended up dying shortly after but I
believe it was a drug an overdose yeah I
read that yesterday yeah so yeah
eugenicists aren't good people no sorry
go ahead Ian well it's an interesting
debate if sex if if uh sexuality is a
state of mind or if it's something
Society puts on you like the label
what's the what does the label even mean
like who I some people are attracted to
some people like that can change from
day to day like I I get so maybe it's
for money like it can make people money
maybe make state of like calm state of
mind to think like I am a this therefore
I have some stability in my life yeah I
mean well I think the people always are
looking for like a sense of community or
just to bond with others like them so
maybe I don't know people I feel like
humans in general like putting labels on
themselves and putting things into
categories his brother did come into
yeah so this is the guy John money this
is I mean what you see happening now in
society is like a direct mirror of his
beliefs and his practices right now it's
like transitioning children and just
making up genders on whim and all of
that was his you know that was his thing
and it's being implemented now on a mass
scale and I think Eugenics is the end
game here because when you look at a lot
of these policies when you look at a lot
of these uh kind of social social
cultural changes what does it lead to
people not having babies people not
being able to have babies people over
sexualized so they don't have families
and
um I think that's the key actually I
think like population control I think
that's probably a big aspect too yeah um
that that's you know because killing
people is messy but if you get people to
kill themselves sterilize themselves
yeah that's true I was just talking
about the that new euthanasia like legal
lies the euthanasia thing but the other
day but um no I think that the
population control is probably a big big
thing behind it too excuse me and that's
why it's being shoved down everyone's
throat in the culture in the movies and
the series and schools on social media
it's all being promoted and so many
Sinister uh ways where people growing up
especially young children growing up
they're inundated with this oh yeah it's
just non-stop to fit in to be accepted
by The Herd you have to be this and to
have Mainline doctors talk about how
much money they're making off of cutting
off the genitalia of small children yeah
is just absolutely sickening it's
disgusting there's no word really for it
but no I think you know because these
puberty blockers when you put a kid on
puberty blockers it's it's these drugs
the drug Lupron is like the most
um most used puberty blocker for
children huh I said Despicable yeah no
and so it is um routinely for for a very
long time only been used to chemically
castrate sex offenders
um because it that's what it does its
chemical castration drug so what they
are doing they're putting these
prepubescent children on these drugs
which will which is going to sterilize
them they will not be able to have
children later on and they know this
very well you know I don't know the
thing is I don't know if the parents
know this like how can a parent I don't
understand parents are part of this too
like a really big problem as Tim said
they show up to the parking lot of CVS
and they're like yeah just put it in me
yeah like I don't know if these doctors
are not making parents aware of the side
effects or well the side effects you
know they're trying to hide the side
effects right now we know for sure that
brain swelling and vision loss are like
two of the big ones from these puberty
blockers as well as sterilization
um and so I just I truly don't
understand how any parent can be on
board with this I think a lot of parents
are like trying to score woke points
somehow especially like these white
liberal women you know they don't know
how else to get woke points
um well a lot of them aren't mentally
stable a lot of them are obese a lot of
them their gut isn't working well and
their brain isn't working well the
father's missing he's not in the home
yeah and
that's so funny I was just gonna say we
call you know there's the transparence
of these little kids that are that want
to transition their children we call
them trans housing by proxy parents or
like Munchausen mommies but we yeah we
say trans housing by proxy because
that's exactly what it is they are using
this they're doing this for themselves
to feel good to say oh look look at me
I'm the mommy in the neighborhood that
has a little trans boy you know like my
my three-year-old daughter is a boy now
like they're they're a bunch of stories
about about like a mom who says all
three of my kids are all trans I've seen
I saw that and it's like what are the
odds because it's like serious uh
statistical anomalies it's it's crazy
because like there's child abuse laws on
the books already I always say this it's
like this stuff needs to fall under that
you know like parents that put their
children on these drugs that that get
them hooked up to the system especially
that take them for surgeries I mean it's
it's
you know you guys know Chloe Cole I'm
sure she's so brave I mean what she's
doing is incredible it's saving like an
Untold number of kids yeah
she's the D transitioner who was put on
puberty blockers at 13 and had a double
mastectomy at 15.
um you know meanwhile the the people
that oppose our organization are telling
us every day this isn't happening you
know Jazz Jennings got genital surgery
at 17. yes before the age of 18. yeah so
these things are happening every day I
mean there was a video that came out
from a clinic a hospital in I in
California I forget exactly where but it
was basically they were in a room and
the and they were talking saying how
like the youngest that they've done it
on is a 12 year old girl like a double
mastectomy that's crazy I'm gonna say
these are healthy children and I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna warn people if
you've got kids in the room but I I want
to say something about this just as a
point of fact
the purpose of what they refer to as
bottom surgery
for uh male to female transgender
individuals serves one purpose and that
is to create a wound which can be used
to sexually stimulate another individual
so to me
you know thinking about this uh I was
talking with another prominent trans
person uh a few you know you know
because they're they're a handful that
are you know relatively conservative or
at least opposed this stuff and they
mention how they're not interested in
what they call bottom surgery because it
doesn't serve a purpose other than
sexual gratification and it's like a
wound and dilation all these things are
really really severe and there are a lot
of videos of these people of many trans
people who are crying over the the pain
that they're experiencing it's kind of
it's kind of sad but like the the only
purpose for it is to create a hole for
which a a person could insert themselves
into for pleasure and I'm kind of like
I mean that's kind of horrifying to me
to be completely honest yeah it's a
wound it is a wound and you know like um
the really horrifying thing I mean
that's very horrifying but even beyond
that is like what they're
um like let's say a child does go on
puberty blockers a boy biological boy
goes on puberty blockers it stunts their
growth so they will never form a fully
grown penis like it will never grow past
the childhood size of a penis because
they are not going through that happened
to Jazz Jennings okay right and so
that's right
um which caused complications right
because there's not enough there's not
enough skin from the penis to invert to
create a vaginal Canal right right it's
not a vaginal Canal no it's not it's
absolutely not it's a you know mimicking
that it's a creation do they call it a
vaginoplasty yeah they do fugazi but
it's called like uh it's not called the
vaginal Canal no not phalloplasty that's
the other one that's the other one
there's a there's a word for the whole
they create and it's not yeah it's yeah
but no so with you know if
trans
whatever I'm so bad at keeping this
stuff straight but like if there's a
biological boy that wants to be a girl
and he knows very very early on whatever
and the parents put him on puberty
blockers he will never grow to the size
he needs to to create that Neo vagina
um I I think and then they use they use
fish skin they use they're using cadaver
skin now they use like uh the colon it's
just it's you know it's some
Frankenstein stuff you can't play like
humans are not able to play God Like
This truly transhumanist it is not only
is it transgender we have transhumanists
all at the same time the trans agenda of
becoming what we think we are not or
becoming what we think we are what
better way to have people give up their
own humanity and transition into this
larger technocratic system than to of
course get rid of their own identity so
that that you know you made the point
there and I agree with you 100 well the
way the way I described it earlier is
that you're going to be living in a pod
you're going to get a deposit of bugs
into your pod to eat you'll strap up on
your VR headset to go into your virtual
Newsroom and you'll be sitting there
then Godzilla will walk in and sit down
King Kong will walk in and you'll be
early to the meeting and they'll say
well you know before we get the meeting
started anybody catch the game last
night and then King Kong and Godzilla
gonna start arguing over you know who's
gonna be the next draft pick in Virtual
NBA then a carrot's gonna walk in sit
down and back everybody please calm down
this meeting in order sales numbers are
off the charts then a rabbit walks in
because people are just going to be
alike identify this way this is what I
am yeah and you're going to live in this
virtual reality where people are just
going to be these creatures and these
things I mean you have kids in school
now identifying as animals right like
they had to put a litter box at once I
don't think that's true I think that was
that was not true no there's there's
kids that are identifying as cats but I
don't think I think I think the litter
box things yeah I've never been able to
confirm or deny it but I'm pretty sure
it came out and said that he got hoaxed
and it wasn't true but I could be right
I don't know if I heard it first from
Joe Rogan it was it was a meme going
around I've never seen sourced by
anything fair yeah can I ask you I don't
know if you talked about this before but
what made you want to to do this what
got you into this I don't know if you
talked about it before um no I I not on
this scale I don't think but um
well you know I I have been against kind
of the the direction that Pride Inc that
uh you know lgbtqia Inc has been headed
in a lot for for years now
um I did not agree with the over
sexualization of everything how Pride
fests and parades have basically just
become you know Kink fests like they
just everything is has um swayed so far
from like the original message of what
we were fighting for equality like tree
quality which was a worthy fight it was
a necessary fight but things you know I
I haven't associated with the community
in a very long time and
um when I saw things happening to like
the red line being crossed was going
after kids like I I was not a fan of the
the pushing Pride down everyone's
throats like all the corporations
changing their their um profile pictures
whatever during pride month but then
they started going after kids and me and
a bunch of my friends
um that are also now part of gays
against groomers they we would speak out
against it but there was no Unified
force and I have had a platform called
the gay who strayed for like six years
now which accumulated a large Following
over time and I basically was just like
you know after seeing all of this just
endless stream of these videos coming
out
um of these drag shows for kids and
seeing the material in schools and
seeing that kids are being medicalized
and transitioned I was uh it got to the
point in June where I was just like I
can no longer sit by with this platform
and try and not try and do something to
stop it from the inside so that's you
know the the name came to my head and
the next day I created the account and
put a team together and just got the
ball rolling and it it exploded people
now yeah we have a lot of people is it a
company is it like an incorporation or a
501c3 uh it's a non-profit we have filed
to be a C4
um it takes like six to nine months to
for that process to be approved
um so yeah we're like I said we're
really new we launched in June of this
past year
um so we've done a lot in a short amount
of time and now we have chapters popping
up all over the place
um and it's just it's great to see you
know in the amount of support that we
have is overwhelming I mean we have
haters out there you know like we have
some some pretty loud notable haters uh
that like to call us anti-trans and
anti-lgbtq that's always a funny one you
know mediamatters has written like eight
articles on gays against rumors now and
they always call us an anti an
anti-lgbtq hate group and it's like
that's weird yeah everybody in the
organization is LGB we don't believe in
the queue like we don't believe in the
queue everybody in the organization is
is either LGB or t What Q is queer what
does it mean well queer was always a
slur you know us older gays I mean I'm
not you know just like not these new
gays that are popping up all over the
place you know that was always a slur I
mean people people use that against us
in a very derogatory way and we we um we
tried to get past that but now it's like
they they reclaimed it and rebranded it
and suddenly we're all just supposed to
be okay with it thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time